so i want to start today by talking
about gay republicans gay republicans at
one point thought hey you know what
they're going to accept us in the
republican party gay marriage is now
legal it's kind of becoming a non-issue
and if we are for low taxes if we are
for low regulation if we
are about christian values whatever that
means at the time that they say it
within the context of the republican
party the republican party will accept
us because it's moved on to other things
and unfortunately uh punctuated with
last week's vote against marriage
equality from 157 different republicans
in the house of representatives it is
now abundantly clear that gay
republicans have failed
at being integrated into the republican
party the republican party is seeing a
sort of resurgence of overt homophobia
now it's important to understand that
overt is the key word
the homophobia never went away from the
republican party there was this moment
after gay marriage was legalized and
donald trump became the republican
nominee where donald trump would say
he's fine with uh gay people and gay
marriage and just kind of look the other
way it's a non-issue and quite frankly
on a personal level i think trump
doesn't care at all about gay marriage i
think he's just it's not even an issue
he really cares about
but slowly but surely and we're going to
talk about this in the next segment as
the christian element of the republican
party has become more overtly
nationalistic and by that i don't mean
they happen to be christians and they
are nationalists i mean they are
christian nationalists specifically
as the trans issue
has gotten good
uh has made headway in re-igniting
some of these visceral cultural issues
social issues for republicans they've
sort of been drawn back to
the base fundamental homophobia that was
a critical part of the republican party
for a long time but
acutely at the end of the george w bush
era and during the barack obama era
there has been
there was a period of time on the show
where we would much more regularly cover
the overt homophobia school homophobia
from the republican party in the bush
era and in the obama era of the david
pakman show
we were often talking about the
outrageous homophobic tirades on the
floor of the house and on various talk
radio programs by right-wing republicans
it was a much more common thing and in
the trump era there was far less of it
now i'm not saying all of a sudden the
republican party was enlightened on gay
rights that's not what i'm saying at all
what i'm saying is they were less
overtly homophobic because they moved on
to other things including the trans
issue it's important to mention well
very interesting article now in the
texas tribune we failed gay republicans
who fought for acceptance in the texas
republican party see little progress
progress gay republicans who have fought
for acceptance within the texas gop over
the past three decades told the texas
tribune progress has been excruciatingly
slow that's quite an understatement many
of them have left the party even as the
number of log cabin republicans in texas
continues to grow log cabin republicans
is a gay republican group
um and the article sort of tells the
story of how there was this
um a period of time i guess we would say
after the aids crisis
uh where there was the idea that listen
uh we're gay but we want low taxes and
we want low regulation and we're
christian family values whatever and the
republican party is a big tent and
they'll welcome us probably as long as
we have donor dollars and there may have
been a brief period of time where it
seemed like that was a plausible thing
but it has stopped
and um fundamentally what this comes
down to is
there is a group of milli
mostly wealthy white gay men
who think will be accepted as the good
guys as long as we more or less say the
right things they might not love us but
they'll look the other way about
being gay
and will be part of the trump gop they
were never really going to be welcomed
into the george w bush gop
during the obama era it was this kind of
transitional phase and then the trump
gop might welcome us but it turns out
that they don't and it's a very similar
thing to caitlyn jenner caitlyn jenner
great caitlyn jenner republican
doesn't like woke
whatever she understands that to mean
doesn't like uh liberals and all this
stuff but then gets booed out of cpac
because of course she did
of course she did and it would sort of
be funny
if it wasn't tragic on multiple levels
i'll tell you what some of those levels
are one level on which the continued
homophobia and transphobia of the
republican party is tragic is that it's
2022
and when you have a duopoly in the
united states there's two major parties
when one of those parties in 2022
remains openly transphobic and
homophobic you see how retrograde and
recalcitrant the country is if you look
at some other countries every country
has homophobia don't get me wrong but
there are countries including some
countries in europe some countries in
south america to a lesser degree with
multi-party systems where you might have
you know six major parties and five
are very much on the same page like
listen of course gay people can get
married of course nobody should be able
to get fired for their real or pursue
perceived sexual orientation and then
you've got like one homophobic party in
the united states we have a duopoly
and one of the two parties
is still
basically overtly homophobic you have
some republicans who are like listen
it's a decided issue it's not like
they're going to cheer gay marriage it's
not like they're going to cheer not
being able to fire people because you
believe that they're gay but they'll say
it's a decided issue and we're moving on
to other things um but it is very
retrograde so that's one level on which
it is tragic the second level on which
it's tragic is the republicans who are
gay who are desperate to be accepted
into this party that just doesn't want
them and they'll probably take their
money in most cases
under not protests but sort of like
turning their nose you you would say
um
but they're not gonna like it and that's
sad as well because listen there's
nothing wrong with being gay and wanting
low taxes and thinking low taxes are the
right thing that that
okay you know people have different
views about what the level of taxation
should be
but
overall the republican party is this
movement that's much more than just low
taxes it's much more than just low
regulation it is increasingly
a fundamentalist christian nationalist
worldview
reactionary in ways that they don't even
fully understand and you'll see some
examples of that later in the show when
we look at the new alex jones conspiracy
theories that even his followers don't
get but it's like it sort of sounds okay
and it's tragic on that level as well
but that's what it is and it seems at
this point the movement for
the gay republicans to be integrated
into the republican party not going
particularly well
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right
without the sugar and without a ton of
carbs they have flavors like cocoa honey
nut fruity peanut butter maybe you want
to go adventurous they've got blueberry
muffin maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below